non soraga se avete presente che ci sono
tra l'altro o la maglietta al contrario
me ne sono accorto adesso per vido epico
non sarete presente raga che ogni tanto
le ragazzine quando incontra un loro
idolo c'è tipo su instagram siano essi
chilometrici per spiegare com'è andato
l'incontro con loro idolo partendo dal
cenozoico magari hanno incontrato e c
ran alle 17 del pomeriggio e partono
dicendo alla sera prima
io stavo mangiando i broccoli con gli
asparagi oggi voglio fare io la
ragazzina i fan girl ante perché ieri
come ormai sapete già tutti i minimi che
faccia la sorpresa il contratto martin
garri e perché ve lo dico in questo
video perché il cazzo se frega di cosa
hai fatto ieri ve lo dico in un video
addirittura perché la giornata di ieri è
stata successe delle cose troppo
ignoranti cioè non avete idea vi lascio
al video
allora siamo a monza stiamo andando da
garics è diverso che a me di vivere il
nome frega un cazzo
voglio garics è la persona che amo di
più nel mondo dopo selena gomez gioco da
limonata lab è facile sono quindi sono
giuseppe c'è tutto c'è anche la pula ma
dettagli adesso in realtà non so se
riusciremo a fare a fare la foto
eccetera plata me non importa mente resa
vedere live
io sono qua per questo però teoria ci ha
detto che forse riusciamo a fare un
meeting e questa cosa è successo e un
attimino utilizzante si dice utilizzante
non me ne frega un cazzo dice noi glielo
dico cosa vuoi papa blog papa perché
papà ciao salve salve siamo noi che
siamo della stampa noi ci sono
giornalisti giornalisti sandro la crisi
siamo giornalisti ve lo giuro
grazie papà perché entriamo agli eventi
più passando per giornalisti noi
dobbiamo mantenere un attimo una linea
autorevole una volta finita legista
resta clip
se avete latine camerino di martin
garics poi non vi spiego con un cazzo di
api intrallazzi raccomandati di imèr
sono entrato nel camerino di martin
garics e c'eravamo io martin garics
fedez la prima cosa lo giuro su dio
la prima cosa che sento
provenire dalla bocca di martin garri si
gira e fa 130 ho avuto un attimo di cosa
si sposa come perché questo cristiano ha
detto 130 e poi c'è la fede li vicino e
lo guardato gli ho detto ma chi ha
spiegato la roba del 130 per che vede se
mi fa cenno di sì ridendo 130 morning
york si vola
io guardo garics gli dico guarda 16
questa roba è sul palco in pubblico
quando fai
l'evento è la gente impazzisce diventa
sheva perché non ha idea di che cosa gli
ho detto ovviamente in inglese non così
liscia che molti mi hanno scritto farina
sei tu che hai detto la vaga di dire 130
proprie gare poi sul palco lato 130 in
verità non sono stato io è stato fedez
prima di meglio sono entrato poi glielo
ribadito perché ho sentito che ha detto
130 e quindi ho detto anch'io vorrei
veramente dillo sul palco che spacchi
tutto è stato troppo divertente
poi abbiamo fa ovviamente non ho
registrato il discorso abbiamo fatto io
e lui abbiamo parlato un po mi sa che da
te che cazzo ne frega la foto è questa
veramente figo
questo è il successo prima dell'evento
vi faccio vedere cose che sono successe
durante l'evento di garri buona visione
[Musica]
nasce martin garics
poi se questo tamarro
[Musica]
niente croce papa
l'aipo ha fatto allarmi
ma cos'è
[Musica]
mi sta bene
scusatemi raga ma anche io sono fan e
dopo filmare il trucco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il problema questi stessi che fini di
basket in uguale molinari quante pasta
hai preso
non vuole
e una bolletta
[Musica]
vabbè
canzoni che i ragazzi in tutto questo
alla fine abbiamo risolto che qua
all'evento c'è anche albano limited e te
perché c'è al bano
adesso chiediamo non servì ad albano chi
siamo
ma che cazzo ci fa al bano o un concerto
di martin harley basta comprato il boom
pratici di di alba non avete capito
niente questo un idolo è niente
ragazzino eravamo venuti in pace a fare
a vedere martin garics questo cesso
questo perché come è un evento pieno di
ragazzi è successo questo ed è questo il
motivo è perché non possiamo andare agli
eventi abbiamo visto carico è stato
molto figo la guest star di oggi che
rimane al bano perché albano è sempre
c'è sempre un frigo abbassando ragazzi
un argomento che non c entra
praticamente nulla però ci tenevo a
dirlo in questo video perché si tratta
di una cosa molto importante che è
avvenuta in questi giorni mi hanno
chiesto di parlarne e io lo faccio
assolutamente compiacere riguarda
ragazzi il discorso del cyberbullismo
non ho ancora mai fatto un video
dedicato a questa cosa è molto presto lo
farò non ho ancora fatto perché quando
parlo di qualche cosa ci tengo ad essere
informato a 360 gradi su tutto quello
che succede quindi voglio fare un video
in cui parlo del bullismo perché so che
tantissima gente ne soffre anche dopo
aver visto 13 io mi sono informato su su
che cosa significa su che cosa succede e
come poter aiutare chi chi ne soffre
insomma perché molti di voi mi scrivono
anche di questa cosa è quindi siccome è
un argomento che riguarda un pochino
tutti ci sta che che non si parli anzi è
doveroso parlarne oggi non vi parlo di
questa cosa perché voglio farci appunto
video dedicato però ieri che la domenica
è entrata in vigore la legge sul
cyberbullismo che cos'è la legge sul
cyberbullismo è una legge che tutela i
minori per il cyberbullismo quindi chi
soffre di cyberbullismo chi soffrirà da
lesionati di cyberbullismo potrà
denunciare proprio denunciare nel vero
senso della parola il bullo da da
quattro soldi che lo sta offendendo sul
web
vi lascio l'articolo in descrizione che
ne parla perché
io ovviamente non sono super ferrato
sull'argomento e non mi va di dirvi cose
che magari poi sono vere a metà quindi
leggetevi l'articolo qua sotto
vi ripeto poi più avanti farò un video
su questa cosa non su questa ma su tutto
l'argomento del bullismo in generale
perché non l'ho mai fatto però volevo
dirvi che da adesso in avanti in b.go
entrata in vigore questa legge e date
un'occhiata
quindi ragazzi io concludo questo video
spero che vi sia piaciuto spero che
albaro si sia divertito portata da
questo alla fine poi vabbè importante
che albano si diverte non ai suoi
ragazzi servizio il rifiuto c'è un
fumetto io mi piace anche i vari social
che coniuga nella descrizione sono stati
fischiati ci dividiamo il prossimo visto
i ragazzi di justin dai justin dai già
sting ci sono tutti tifano vederti dai
tasti notte
[Musica]